how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today
loki episode 3 has been released on
disney plus
and although this episode was the
shortest episode and didn't have a
really big climax at the end of it
it perhaps was the most important
episode so far
and there were a lot of major reveals in
this episode and character development
as well and a really
important part about this episode is
that it looks like we have established
a villain and this villain is not sylvie
all the trailers for loki and episode 1
and 2 led us to believe that this
variant of
loki sylvie however in this episode we
learned that's not actually the case
and they are setting up a much bigger
villain in the loki series
and of course i'll break it all down in
this video plus i have some pretty big
theories coming up this week so be sure
to subscribe and hit the notification
bell so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos
so like with most of my breakdowns i'm
going to start with a couple of theories
that i think
are actually going to play out in this
series now probably the biggest thing
that we learned from loki episode 3
is that the tva isn't what we thought
they were
or what even the tva members think that
they actually are in loki episode 1 we
were told that the time keepers created
the tva
and everyone inside of the tva and
everyone
inside of the tva mobius all of the
hunters
the other tva employees this is what
they all believe
except for maybe judge renslayer and
i'll get to that in just a second but in
this episode the big reveal was that
that's a lie that's not actually the
case the timekeepers did not create
all of these people that are now a part
of the tva instead we learned that these
are actually
variants variants of real actual people
from the sacred timeline and if you
think about it it makes perfect sense
why would the timekeepers create all of
these workers for the tva and have them
all
look different and act different and
have their own personalities that would
take a lot of work to create a bunch of
different people with a bunch of
different character traits but instead
we learned that they are actually
variants and it's clear that
somebody at the tva wiped their memories
and then gave them a false sense of
reality telling them that they were
created by the timekeepers and their
whole lives were spent at the tva
what this means is that there is an
actual villain here and the villain is
coming in the form of the timekeepers
these are the true villains of the loki
series three beings who are kind of
doing whatever they want with time and
reality
as we learned in episode 2 they are
forging the sacred timeline into what
they want it to be what they think it
should be and they're also the ones that
kidnap these variants erased their
memories and gave him a lie
so silvie is not the enemy she's
actually the hero
now i'm going to double down on my
theory that kang
is actually behind this king the
conqueror the master of time travel
i firmly believe that that middle time
keeper that we saw on the very first
episode of loki is
kang and i think the other two might be
variants of him as well or perhaps he
made the timekeepers up and it's really
just him
controlling everything with ranslayer
you see ravana renslayer in the comics
is actually the lover of kang the love
of his life who originally doesn't love
him back but eventually comes around
and isn't it very interesting how she is
the only person who can communicate with
the timekeepers
i mean mobius is pretty high up on the
tva and he hasn't met them
why is it only her well it could be
because she knows
the truth it could be that she knows
that kang is really the one behind
everything and she's in on it or
there's always the possibility that she
is the same she's a variant taken from a
timeline she had her memory erased and
she thinks she's just a loyal tva
agent regardless kang is probably in
love with her and chose her to be the
top dog for a reason
now the big question that everybody has
been asking now is
what exactly is going to happen to the
tva members by the end of the loki
series well in this episode it was made
pretty clear
that sylvie is trying to find the
timekeepers and it looks like she pretty
much plans to
kill them she clearly knows that they've
been telling the tva a lie
and knows that they've kidnapped
hundreds of thousands and probably
millions of people that city was pretty
big
so the timekeepers are basically playing
god and making destiny and fate whatever
they decide it to be
which is obviously a problem for any
loki variant and really just kind of any
person
ever so let's say sylvie and loki are
successful they eliminate the
timekeepers what happens to the tva
well i imagine all of them will be
somewhat woken
up their memories will somewhat come
back and perhaps they may
even be able to return to their old
timeline or create a new timeline since
the timekeepers wouldn't be there to
erase
new timelines obviously this connects to
multiverse of madness so i think by the
end of the loki series we're going to
have some
pretty chaotic timeline mess but
regardless of
whatever happens i better get owen
wilson on a jet ski saying
wow if that doesn't happen a huge missed
opportunity
now there were a lot of things explained
in this episode that we need to talk
about so
let's get started with the breakdown in
the beginning we are greeted with
a scene that seems rather confusing at
first silvia is with hunter c20 and they
appear to be really good friends
now really it's just sylvie manipulating
memories that hunter c20 had in the past
as we know
now at least she was an actual person in
an actual timeline now this
actually takes place at the ending of
loki episode 2
in rox cart at the end of episode 2
hunter c20 explains that she gave it all
away she gave away the position of the
timekeepers and this scene is of her
giving it away
now when sylvie is asking her all of
these things inside of her old memories
she does say that she does remember the
place so it does establish that the
memories of all of these variants that
work for the tva
are still there they're just being
blocked by the time keepers or
some source now ultimately sylvie gets
the better end of hunter c20
and figures out the location of the
timekeepers we see the title card and
then we cut to sylvie actually entering
the tva
now she goes up to one of the hunters
and tries to use an enchantment on him
however right when she tries you notice
a look on her face
she realizes that it doesn't work the
hunter is a little startled but then he
takes out his weapon and tries to
essentially erase sylvie
unfortunately she gives him one kick
which causes him to drop it and then she
erases him
now remember she is loki she's a variant
of loki so her magic is kind of the same
and as we learned in the very first
episode of loki magic does not work in
the tva
so even silvie's magic is limited in the
tva now of course as we saw in the
ending of episode 2 loki also goes
through the portal to go back to the tva
he arrives and then he retrieves his
daggers that hunter b15 put in her
locker
then we have an interesting moment when
loki and silvi interact with each other
loki asks her if she is sure she's a
loki
now this is kind of funny because the
entire fandom has been wondering if she
actually is
a lady version of loki or if she's
actually enchantress
given that her name is sylvie however in
this episode she does say that she was
indeed loki she just essentially created
an
alias for herself called sylvie now in
marvel comics sylvie was the actual name
of enchantress but it's pretty clear
that this is not enchantress it's most
likely just an easter egg too
enchantress however
maybe sylvie will have some powers of
enchantress they actually did this with
hella and thor ragnarok she was really
hella an
enchantress combined into one character
which is something they could be doing
for sylvie but it is defined in this
episode that sylvie is
a variant of loki now judge rinslayer
then comes around the corner with two
hunter guards and sylvie immediately
threatens to kill loki
because loki is kind of working for the
tva however the only reason loki is
working for the tva is to try and catch
sylvie so when sylvie says she'll kill
loki rinse later doesn't care she's
after sylvie so she tells her to do it
now of course loki isn't about to just
sit there and die so he steals the tva
time travel device
and he sends them through a portal now
silvi kind of gets the best of loki when
they arrive through the portal and she
grabs the device and tries to teleport
away
and open a portal but the device is low
on battery and is essentially dead
and doesn't work now from here we
actually see some of loki's abilities
that we really haven't seen before
in this scene right here we learned that
loki can actually teleport he uses his
teleportation abilities to get the
device back from
silvi but the two of them have bigger
problems as loki has taken them to
lamentus
1 which silvi says was the biggest
apocalypse there has ever been
it's also in the future in 2077 which
implies that
silvi knows a lot about the future and
has jumped through many different
timelines
now sylvia explains that the moon and
the planet are about to collide and
everybody's going to be destroyed
including them if they don't get off the
moon now loki has the tim pad and silvi
doesn't know how to get it from him but
loki doesn't know how to recharge it
silvi needs it because apparently loki
interrupted a plan that was years and
years in the making which is of course
for sylvia to find the timekeepers and
kill them so the two of them come to a
truce and they start to work together
now sylvie says they just need enough
power to recharge the tim pad so they
can travel through interdimensional time
and space
this is because the tva essentially
exists outside of time
and the tim pads allow the tba members
to travel from outside of time
into different timelines and time
periods now as they walk to find power
this is where we find out that sylvie
was indeed loki
she says that's not who i am anymore i'm
sylvie now
it's an alias now from here we
essentially learn what sylvie's plan was
and loki is the one that actually tells
us he says your plan was to tear the
place down
create the ultimate power vacuum of
destruction and walk away
and silvi basically says yep this would
ultimately accomplish her
purpose of tearing down the tva and
getting rid of the timekeepers and
essentially creating a multiverse of
madness a multiverse where she has true
freedom and her fate isn't decided by
the timekeepers but she might also have
a different motive here
later on in the episode she states that
she had been running from the tva since
she was very very young so perhaps this
simply could just be about her
trying to get the tva off her back and
the only way to do that
is to destroy them now loki and sylvia
come across somebody who is actually in
their home
loki says brute force won't work so
silvia opens the door to immediately get
shot by some kind of energy cannon or
some type of sound wave cannon
loki attempts to try and trick the lady
by transforming into her old husband but
she sees right through him ultimately
the lady tells them that there's an ark
that takes off it's going to leave the
moon and save whoever is on it and the
way to get there
is by train however to get on the train
you need a ticket we get there and we
hear some people say they're only giving
out tickets to the wealthy and here we
start to see more differences between
loki and sylvie even though they are the
same
just different variants they don't think
the same way silvi wants to enchant a
guard
and walk them through however loki's
plan is to simply be the guard himself
now as you can imagine loki's plan
didn't work and silvia had to step in
ultimately getting them on the train to
the ark and here is where
sylvie and loki start to bond sylvie
says she's not going to look for the
temp pad because she probably
can't find it because she admits that
somebody taught loki fairly decent magic
now of course loki reveals that it was
actually his mother
now as we've learned loki's mother is a
very important figure to him perhaps the
person he loves most but here in this
scene we learn
just how different the lives of these
two different loki's are
when loki is talking about how good his
mother was sylvie makes a joke and says
are you sure she was your mother and
loki says actually no i was adopted
sorry if that's a spoiler for you but
sylvie says she knew she was adopted
and of course as most of us know loki
was actually a frost giant
son of laffy which is why he is loki
lafay sun but of course he loved his
mother and we find out that
sylvie actually doesn't really remember
much of her mother now it's not really
stated on whether or not
she died when silvia was really young or
if something else happened but the key
difference here is that loki's mother
frigga taught
him magic whereas sylvie taught herself
including enchanting people
pretty much mind controlling them and
casting illusions in their minds
now from here it's rather interesting
but we get into the topic of
love and sylvie says something that
implies that her life
could have actually been quite different
from loki's now she talks about how she
had a bow but it wasn't too serious it
was only something to keep her going but
then she says
how about you you're a prince and look
at the way she says this
would be princesses or perhaps
the way she says this kind of seems like
she may not be a princess
so perhaps whatever happened in her
timeline resulted in her not being
a princess of asgard and then we get the
really big reveal
that loki is actually bisexual sylvie
asked him if he ever had any princesses
or
princes waiting for him and he says a
bit of both
and if there is any confusion on whether
or not this means he's bisexual the
director
kate herron did come out on twitter and
state that it was very important to her
and one of her goals to acknowledge that
loki was bisexual so if you are somewhat
confused
don't be loki is bisexual this is canon
to the mcu confirmed and it's a pretty
big deal and i'm happy for those people
who this means a lot to
now sylvia actually ends up falling
asleep and she wakes up to a drunken
loki singing in between english and
asgardian now here when he finishes his
drink he slams it on the ground and
yells another this is just like what
thor did in the very first thor film
when he's drinking coffee in the diner
he drinks his coffee throws a glass on
the ground and yells another
[Music]
now during all the chaos we actually
learned something about sylvie she
says she's paranoid because she spent
her entire life
running from the omniscient fascist you
work for now of course she is referring
to the tva who she calls the time police
now this may have significant meaning
this may mean that
sylvie or this loki variant is different
from the others
did she commit a crime that made the tva
chase her or perhaps were they trying to
get her for something else
clearly the time keepers aren't exactly
the best of people as they are taking
variants and
essentially erasing their memories and
then brainwashing them since the tva can
see into the future
maybe they realize that sylvie is
actually their doom
and that's the reason they've been
chasing her her entire life i'm sure
there's more to this that will be
revealed in future episodes
now loki is drunk and it doesn't really
work out for the two of them
the guards come and because loki is
drunk when he tries to use his magic to
create fake tickets he ends up doing
fireworks again that he showed sylvia
before
this of course leads to a fight and
there are two key moments here
one of them is we see more magic being
used by loki he actually uses his magic
in the form of green energy blast
something we've never seen before the
second part is silvie actually takes off
her horns or i should say horn
and uses it to stab one of the guards
and then if you notice
one of the guards actually ends up
throwing it back at her but she dodges
it
however she never picks it back up loki
gets thrown out of the window and since
he has the tin pad she jumps after him
and if you notice from here on out she
never wears it again because it's still
on the train
now when they both finally land on the
ground and get up sylvie puts her sword
to loki's throat and says give me the
temp pad
and loki says okay and he reveals that
it's broken
however i don't believe this to be true
i believe this is an
illusion by loki every time sylvie has
asked for the tin pad loki has said
no he's refused to give it to her this
entire time and of course knowing loki's
character he would never give it to her
however in this scene
he immediately says okay so i don't
believe this is the real temp pad i
believe he's still holding on to it and
i think this will be revealed next
episode and i think this is going to be
how they get off of lomantus one because
at the end of the episode the ark got
destroyed which was seemingly their only
way out
however more on that in just a bit now
from here we actually see a little bit
more of
sylvie's powers silvi states that loki
pretty much destroyed her mission and
loki kind of taunts her stating that you
can't beat them referring to the tva and
the timekeepers
from here her hands light up green and
she emits an explosive blast of
essentially anger and these blasts are
kind of similar to the one that loki did
on the train
now from here loki proposes that they go
and take over the ark and essentially
make sure it gets
off of the moon sylvia agrees and the
two of them start to walk towards the
ark and here is where we get
two big reveals one is that sylvie and
loki kind of start to trust each other
and sylvie reveals how her enchantment
works she reveals that she has to make
physical contact which is why we see her
fingers
actually touch the heads of who she
enchants then she has to grab their
minds and she explains that the weak
minds are pretty easy to take over the
stronger ones however require a bit
of work and she has to create fantasies
from their memories
to stay in control and this is where the
second big reveal comes
she says that the young soldier from the
tva's mind was messed
up it was very clouded and she had to
pull memories from hundreds of years ago
before she even fought for the tva
and this is huge news loki says i
thought the tva were created by the
timekeepers in which sylvie says that's
ridiculous they're all
variants and of course this is news to
us and loki and loki states that they
don't know that even the variants that
work for the tva don't know that but
that is because as sylvia explained
their mind is being clouded most likely
by the time keepers
or king now from here sylvie and loki
make it to the ark but right as they get
there
the planet that the moon is about to
crash into breaks in half and debris
from it starts to crash into the ground
from here sylvie and loki run around
randomly fighting guards
trying to find their way onto the ark
and here's where we see a very
very interesting scene a pillar is
falling down
and loki says i got it and then stops
the pillar from falling
however if you take a close look at this
he's not just using telekinesis to stop
it from falling it looks like he is
actually reversing
its time if you pay careful attention it
seems very clear that he
reversed it so does loki have the
ability to make
objects go backwards in time i'm not so
sure about that
however we do know that loki did come in
contact
with a lot of infinity stones inside of
the tva
and of course it's loki he most likely
took some so
does he have the time stone on him and
could he have perhaps
used that time stone to stop this pillar
in time and then
reverse it now we didn't see the time
stone or anything glow green or any
runes pop up like they do for doctor
strange but this
is loki he knows magic so perhaps he
could have manipulated the time stone in
some way
and reverse this pillar from falling
because remember the time stone and the
infinity stones don't work inside of the
tva
but in this scene they're not in the tva
they're outside of the tva on
a timeline lomantis one so the time
stone
would work here loki is the god of
mischief so i do think ultimately he
took a handful of infinity stones for
himself because of course he was
planning his escape the entire time and
when he finally escaped in his mind he
would have a bunch of infinity stones to
use but you'll have to let me know what
you think about this
do you think it's the time stone or do
you think loki actually has this ability
somehow
now overall i know a lot of people in my
live chat last night said that this
episode was pretty underwhelming but
after watching it again
i think it might have been my favorite
episode i love the dynamic between
sylvie and loki there were a lot of
amazing scenes in it that were very
cinematic there were also some very
quiet tinder scenes that i enjoyed there
were some big reveals about loki's
powers and then of course we had the big
tva reveal which also revealed that
there is a
big villain behind the tva but let me
know in the comments down below
what you would rate this episode 1 out
of 10. 10 being the highest
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof
you